[Music]
in sad times news it's all Siam are you
okay seasonal depression
wait CSS ad yeah what seasonal
depression in that like summertime
springtime one-time fall time all the
seasons
you know what season but you don't say
like no but because I hear you hear that
Christmas time is the most suicidal time
of the year but then you hear summers
are really suicidal times that's really
pretty I guess not Valentine's Day it
depends depends on what the person with
the SAV views other people was being
happy during like so if holidays
everyone's happy and they're not happy
it's a reminder of house out there and
so as it was summertime everyone's out
having fun and and then like they don't
feel like how do you know if you just
you're just depressed you can't have
general depression like having another
different well because you would only
get sad during those seasons it's like
it's like half a seasons for all but
when I'm sad and I see other people
happy I get happy you don't have it
usually has to do with sunlight to
that's why it's this that's what I have
in every time it's overcast not if it's
not if it's raining but overcast like
calories right now I get crazy anxiety
like I don't know why I just think that
the world's gonna end like I feel like I
want to matter Abed yeah I like gloomy
days it makes me calm not but not the
gray goo and like that's fine but like
this white like reflective kind I don't
know what it is I swear when Nicky was
two or something her dad every time is
overcast he's like some [ __ ] like that
cuz what the hell cause I don't know
maybe the world does end well not
overcast and I'm just psychic about it
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
I know the witches are no video games
I do oh that's a great distraction yeah
how you try those Sun lamps they do
those it just acts like real sunlight
and you get your vitamin D that way
that's like like I just kind of my
sister needs a man you could put it on
your reptile are those red those are the
red one oh that's for the tarantula me
and I roast peanuts cuz I like putting
peanuts on like
dude my sister's skin is so white
my sister's skin is so much she looks
like an Abigail or some [ __ ] what's her
name Jennifer Jennifer not as good as
Avenue that's like peak perfection
Agatha butter Turner lady person that's
what that sounds like Edna oh yeah
that's good a beloved principal died
after Isis I escaped submitted by
Instagram foodie which could be like
anyone I guess David yeah no don't call
him that
you the real foodie I'm gonna call him
whatever I want he's gonna show up today
nice that's right he's making food it's
leather I think you can tell a beloved
principal died after donating bone
marrow to someone he never met oh I read
about this that's why I don't think
about donating blood organ or anything
like you lose your marrow and it's over
dude why do you want to give your body
parts to somebody I don't understand I
am NOT a donor are you donor yeah I mean
we're gonna do but you're also a [ __ ]
chump did but then I took it off the
last time I got a new license and it's
still on there oh wait hold on why don't
you get some of the organ are you
serious yeah we ought to bring it back
because they don't want to bring you
back to life and think it's false
oh is it false as myth do you have the
confirmation do you have the document I
talked to the doctors
all of them alive every doctor you talk
to some honest people sure you didn't
get your kidney stones from all that
energy drink I don't want to come back
to life are you talking about Oh welcome
at the way you do well like if you tried
a couple times could be a mortal ass
book a mortal
okay it took me time yeah I said it
his name was Derrick 44 years old he
died after he lapsed into a coma during
a donation procedure for him to donate
bone marrow to this 14 year old boy in
France who he's never met you probably
have enough zinc you know what's
interesting like this guy should just
very clearly not have done this because
he had medical complications already
that he couldn't go under general
anesthesia because he had sleep apnea
and so that makes sedation extremely
dangerous so instead they put him under
local anesthesia doctors weren't able to
draw blood from his arms because he
carried this trait for sickle cell
anemia blood disorder from like why is
he donated me he wanted to kill himself
suicide that's what I was thinking
peaceful way to go out I don't think so
I think he was there for legitimate
reasons and they put him on dirt and oh
[ __ ] he's a daughter like what easily
should sleepy sorry so even though you
died was he able to save the kid because
they were able to get the bad marrow
this will save the boy but that they are
still sending him like what's the
process like the my cousin had to get
donate bone marrow for to save her
brother's life to the bone it's not
through like injections I think they
drills no it's not like cutting a bone
and escaping I mean it's hot it's hard
to get through there yeah that's one
more time so that everyone in this
community is mourning him because he was
a very giving person he sounds like a
gaming purse he gave it like he's like
the giving tree' so he was principal
he's also a dad I like to judge books by
the cover he looks a dead marine wait
what is it thank you for your service
sir he did the army reserve for more
than 20 years Wow and he's a dad and a
principal oh so his kids you know god
he's so active dude I might don't be
this active you're gonna die what people
wore that active dude it's like man have
a [ __ ] do you even like sit down and
relax like you don't parts probably
constantly going like this man that's
gotta be bad for you yeah doctors yeah
so you survived by his mom it's Beyonce
and their six-year-old daughter so [ __ ]
you just decided to give bone marrow
just to some random person cuz yeah I
don't know why exactly but because he's
boy she cares about the world he just
cares see like I'm I'm like your average
carer like I retweet [ __ ] you know me
like I retweet I spread awareness online
you know what I mean like and I use this
platform to spread awareness
I'll watch like a hurricane relief show
watch it yeah Oh watch out yeah I'll
check it out I'm like if there's a good
like this line of artists oh my gosh
yeah watch Marie Kondo and then I
[ __ ] give a ton of [ __ ] to like
charity to clean out my house and [ __ ]
dude when I was a kid I donated like
$40,000 to Nickelodeon's the big help
because I was just wanting to call in
line and hearing voices and [ __ ] and
then I probably went outside for like 15
minutes I was like this is [ __ ]
boring
I used to be I used to get like I used
to go to like church when I was little
so we have to do all these like
community service things right I used to
walk in hate that [ __ ] because it's like
your florist community so yeah I didn't
you don't know like you're a child right
and then you keep doing it until like
junior high or whatever and you're like
I can't [ __ ] do this did you have to
get community service hours at your
school are your high school
mmm feel like honors programs
oh [ __ ] I thought that was a regular
thing but you know everybody that
graduated my school had to do 40 hours
of community service that's a lot yeah
and so I did mine at the kitten shelter
scientists like got to raise kittens
cute do when I was a kid I was picking
up trash on the road to be a good person
whatever cuz just want some planet Earth
documentary things
and then I just see like a car driving
by and they just throw a whole [ __ ]
thing up there trying to help out we
were stupid kid exactly
I do get here's though what I'm in
nature and I see trash yeah and I go
next time I bring a bag [ __ ]
yup I'm gonna pick that [ __ ] up next
time never do I come to the beach i'ma
come with a trash bag I could that's
that's something that's crossed my mind
too doesn't pick up dog [ __ ] I've
thought about it yeah but I don't pick
it up I do pick up my own dog [ __ ]
though sorry I'm already doing a service
that's a big service yeah it is do you
do anything terrible no absolutely not I
also go to the kitten rescue
organizations annual like charity event
and we donate money there but it's kind
of like I donated through the silent
auction and I'm really drunk off the
open bar drinks and I usually walk home
with like $400 worth of like auction
prizes that I didn't even remember it's
for charity we borrow some things for
charity we buy things for ourselves for
church good person you guys everybody
knows like promotional videos for
charities I works on this one where was
like influencers like come together like
a PSA please you know there are kids who
are bubble anyways like it's kind of
[ __ ] like the people who are in
charge of it or like clearly just like
using this as some like tax right Oh
hundred percent oh that's why I'm
personally against a lot of them because
I know the [ __ ] it's a con yeah it's
it's it's a tax move it's a con and what
they're doing is they're using people
that are maybe passionate about the
organization that have no [ __ ] clue
how what's going on and then they came
up with them and then like maybe
influencers that actually care and in
people that actually care they funnel
all this money up and then guess what 70
sango's administration dude all the rich
people man like [ __ ] bill Mun the
Gates Foundation dollar [ __ ] they dunk
hundreds of millions of dollars of their
own money into their own foundation so
they don't have to pay taxes on the [ __ ]
it's incredible and they pay themselves
as employees within the they get to be
good people and not pay taxes [ __ ]
amazing but it's a money move do you
guys remember that one with Jerome the
Viner friends Reiner do and then he like
teamed up with Ben Stiller to help
people with Somalia
sounds like a joke you like do you hear
the one about the guy that Latino Ben
Stiller no you really didn't plan to
send to Somalia filled with like food as
well anyway I was I was part of like
because they had this thing where you
could donate every month like every
month a take out I think was like twenty
bucks or something and I was part of
that for some time and I was like this
feels good but then after some time I'm
like I think I've donated enough it's
over and but I guess badass like he was
literally top of vine like at least top
three for a hot minute and then he's
like nah screw this I'm just gonna
become like a social media yeah I'm sure
there's good ones out there I just don't
know and out of the mountain of [ __ ]
that there is it's difficult because you
have to really figure out like what's
really going on with each organization
my cousin used to do accounting for a
lot of nonprofits because he wanted to
give his help to these you know
organizations by doing it that way and
he uncovered so much shitty secrets and
he's like you're a nonprofit
organization that's supposed to be
helping people like in poverty why do
you have a corner office in downtown why
do you need that much square footage why
do you need to buy all these su are you
renovating why do you have [ __ ]
crystal walls and [ __ ] yeah and and so
for him he just was not cool with being
tied to these like that [ __ ] and he's
like I don't want to help them anymore
like this is [ __ ] [ __ ] you walk
into all those places it's like [ __ ]
beautiful fountains and she's like a ham
this could have been a well in Africa or
like 70 wells project they build wells I
like that one yeah I don't you don't
know it could be for the cheese and your
waterfall
so even more money from the new a guy
they pay tomorrow so it's like Fung Shui
the place thank you
we're gonna start a JK charities oh yeah
a little money tax shelter dude money
laundry
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]